hello everyone and welcome to the
semi-finals of the fiji world cup 2021
uh it's
sergey karjakin versus vladimir ferozev
and uh this is already round two i
haven't covered any games from round one
because
let's face it it was it was a snooze
fest and there was nothing to cover
also i had guests uh so i decided to
start with round two i
thought probably in round two uh we were
gonna have some fireworks and
fireworks uh we we will have uh so this
is the second game really an awesome one
uh like first 20 moves are pure theory
so we're not going to dwell too long on
that but after that
it's going to be really really awesome
so let's see what happened
uh karjakin with the white pieces opens
with e4 fedor
goes e5 we have knight to f3 knight to
c6 and the bishop to b5 so the rule
lopez is on the board
uh as the title might suggest we have a6
bishop to a4
uh morphy's defense of course uh and now
knight to f6 we have castles
uh bishop to e7 and now rook to e1 so
pretty much the moves you see in any
uh rue lopez we have b5 attacking the
bishop bishop to b3 and d6 now keeping
it a closed game
we have c3 now preparing d3 or d4 in the
future and we have
castles we have h3 taking away the g4
square from black's pieces
and bishop to b7 now we have d4 striking
in the center and
rook to e8 the bishop is coming to f8
but this is
uh something you already know so knight
uh i beat the d2 we have bishop to f8
and
now a3 uh we have h6 by black
bishop back to c2 and now uh the most
popular idea here is just to go back
knight b8 and then strike striking the
center with c5 but here
we have d5 it's not a new move it's been
played before
uh so just uh challenging the center and
now there's a lot of pressure in the
center you have to do something about
this
you could capture with the e pawn you
could capture with the deep one you
could capture with the knight so
anything is possible in the game karya
can win the d
captures knight captures knight captures
rook captures in the now
knight to f3 attacking the rook f4 uh
also a very popular move here knight to
f3 attacks the rook rook the e8
uh and now we have e5 attacking this
knight
and interestingly this position has been
reached before but it was never won
uh by the player playing the with the
black pieces so
uh most of them were drawn some of them
were won by white so maybe something to
to consider if you uh decide to choose
this line of
for black uh and not knight to e4 the
only good movie
if you go on knight d7 for example let's
say queen d3 threatens checkmate g6 and
e6 black just falls apart
there's no defending this so instead
after e5 we have knight to e4
and now comes bishop to f4 so just
nicely continuing development we have c5
black finally gets his c5 move in and
now a4
challenging the structure here with f5
by black again not a new move
uh and here node moves our knight to d2
just further challenging this knight
and also queen to e2 but in this game we
have
h4 and it is only now as of move 20
uh that we have a completely new game uh
so let's see how fidosev uh
uh uh deals with this new idea
he starts uh by uh playing bishop to e7
now here uh
you could consider a lot of things uh
the engine
after a long consideration uh suggests
just b captures on a4 but
that's a move as uh as a human you you
kind of don't even consider
queen to b6 continuing development also
an option he decides to go for bishop to
e7
uh puts pressure on the h4 pawn and now
uh karjakin goes
h5 and what he did with this
is that he created a very nice outpost
for his knight on g6
now the knight could come here via the
h4 square for the moment not possible
because the bishop and queen cover that
square
but there is also another possibility
here we have rook to f8 by black
and now we have a captures a captures
rook
captures an a8 bishop captures the queen
should remain in the center of the board
and
now e6 and now the e5 square has been
freed for the night and now you could
also reach this square
via the e5 score 95 knight to g6 so this
could be
very good for white and here we have
rook
back to e8 the problem if you go for
rook to f6 if you go after the pawn
then knight to h4 is possible the bishop
and queen no longer guard that square
now if you capture here we're going to
capture on f5 and now
white is well white's position is just
better here
uh the the black king side is well
completely ruined so instead after e6 we
have rook to e8 fedorsev we'll try to do
something about the spawn this way
but now knight to e5 now we're going
after this
g6 square uh via the e5 square we have
bishop to g5
and now still knight to g6 and here we
have a really really awesome
position where you could try a lot of
things but none of them really work
best for black is i'm just gonna show it
to you because it's uh well it's best
for black is bishop captures on f4
and now after knight captures queen to
g5
now we do have a lot of pressure here
attacking the knight maybe if the pawn
moves
maybe we can get some pressure here on
the g2 pawn but
white will play queen to f3 and still
white is definitely to be preferred here
but
this is how black should continue
another very interesting option is just
capturing the pawn this is only
interesting it's not good it loses on
the spot
because bishop captures on g5 queen
captures and now f3
the rook is undefended so the knight
cannot move however black can
capture on h5 now put pressure on this
knight but now
knight f4 attacks the queen and the rook
now comes queen to h4
super tricky because we cannot go after
the rook if we grab the rook then queen
f2 checking h1 queen h4 check and we
have a nice perpetual here with the
queen
so first we're gonna eliminate the
knight and only after queen captures on
f4 now we play bishop captures on d5 and
now we win the game
bishop captures queen captures there's a
double attack on the rook you can't move
the rook it's pinned that's it
so uh just in case uh you were wondering
if it's okay to grab the e6 pawn
so here we have d for by philosoph uh
but
um even even this will not suffice so
here we have c
captures on d4 now he has this beautiful
knight captures on f2 move and it it
works well if
uh karjakin wants to keep material
balance but he's not interested in that
he plays king captures on f2 bishop
captures on f4
knight captures on f4 and now queen to
h4 check
and now the thing is if you play g3 then
fedocer gets a draw
queen to h2 check king f1 and now we
just repeat king queen h1 king of two
queen h2 king f1
and now we go for this very nice
repetition and if you
try and uh run away with later king the
e2 it
we still play queen to h2 check and now
you have to go back you can't really go
anywhere else if king to d3 then we
start capturing queen g3 pick up the
knight
and then it's black who's winning so you
would have to go back queen each one
check and so on get a draw
but after queen to h4 check karyakin
just played king back to g1 he said you
can have the knight
my position is winning why would i
settle for this so queen captures on f4
and now d5
locking out this light squad bishop
completely out of the game
for the moment but having now two
connected past pawns on d5 and e6 this
is incredible if the pawn gets the d6
and d7 that's game over
so here uh you might try a lot of things
uh
i'm just going to show you what happens
if you let's say block with the queen
which definitely makes sense you block
the pawns and you're preparing to
capture on d5
there's bishop captures on f5 queen
captures on the e5
uh bishop captures is something you want
to play but it's not very good because
uh uh well there's just bishop e4 and we
win the game
uh there's a double attack on the bishop
if the rook joins in
we play e7 and uh you know there's no
way to
to continue this so uh instead after
this bishop captures an f5 we will have
to play queen captures on d5
and now white will very happily trade
here queen captures bishop captures and
now
rook to e5 attack the bishop after the
bishop moves we can
eliminate the pawn but also if the
bishop moves you could also play
something like e7
and there's no move black can make the
rook can't move otherwise we queen the
pawn
if you play king f7 then this is just
winning bishop picks up the rook
so there's really no move that black can
play here so queen to d6 although a move
you want to play
uh loses the game so here if those have
tried queen to g3
it uh kind of makes sense because you
know now uh
well the the rook here is under attack
so you have to be very careful he'll
bishop captures on d5 is the threat
queen captures queen captures on e2 but
it's also a move that uh
loses to one very specific move this is
a really really difficult move to find
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this incredible move
for karjakin while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
finding the only move that wins for
white and for those of you who want to
enjoy the show
it's rook to e2 yes it's a it's a really
a silly looking move but it gets the job
done
so now the all of the ideas that you
we've tried before simply don't work uh
because there there's nothing to
to try here uh let me just
check one thing really quickly uh sorry
about that
this is super important
oh yeah okay yeah
uh so uh after this move there's really
nothing to do
uh because you can't really move
anything and
none of the the defensive ideas work um
the problem is if you play something
like king to f1 which is a
pretty pretty reasonable thing to do uh
sorry the
the interface is giving me uh some
trouble here
after rook to rook to e2 yeah uh if you
play something like uh
king to f1 instead of this rook d2 then
queen to d6 is actually pretty okay
because now after bishop captures on f5
uh sorry after bishop captures an f5
bishop captures on d5 we don't have to
capture with the queen now it's possible
to capture with the bishop
and now it's uh you know you're not
going to get a lot of winning chances
here if king to g1 we can still play
queen to g3 now if queen captures here
then queen captures here and it's uh
still a game so after this uh rook the
e2 move
we have queen to g5 by fedocif uh but
here
sergey just played uh queen to d2 and
uh incredible as it is uh it was in this
position on move 33
that uh vladimir have resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
you could prolong the game by by just
moving pieces a little bit but
other than that you really don't have a
a choice
it's impossible for black to activate
any of the pieces the bishop completely
locked in the rook not doing anything
the king here
uh let's say you trade queens queen
captures rook captures there's
nothing you can do the the pawn is just
marching forward it's uh you know
you're gonna lose this there's really
nothing for you to do here
uh if you try something like king to f8
we can
pretty much just do anything just d6 and
that's it i mean all of these squares
are now taken away from the black king
uh and there's nothing to do if rook
captures on e6 we just push the pawn
uh not nothing to it and there's there's
no defending this
so uh it's a really really impressive
game and it's a very
uh it's not easy to pinpoint uh just
where fedocev went wrong
uh but we could uh like okay karjakin
uh made uh uh made a new new game with
this h4 move
and then probably had to continue uh you
know uh a bit more active with b
captures on a4
queen to b6 because after bishop e7 and
h5 there really wasn't all that much you
could do
it was it was like a really really good
position for white
and you needed a surgical precision to
survive this with the white pieces
yeah after queen to d2 uh fidos have
resigned and uh sergey karyakin is the
first one to reach the finals
of the video world cup 2021 uh and we'll
see who will meet him there whether
it'll be magnus carlsen or young
schistoduda that all depends on how
their second game goes first one ended
in a draw as you already know
so uh it's either going to be uh
karjakin versus duda or karayakin versus
carlsen either way it's going to be a
lot of fun so
sorry once again about the that
interface thing even though i don't
think
you guys actually saw anything but um
you know sometimes it just happens uh
but yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank uh
leonard bonk abhirovsky david pederson
uh jeffrey johnson and michael
hildebrand for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
world cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank y'all i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day